Ils l'ont battue, ils l'ont violée
les femmes coupent la mort comme
Ils l'ont tuée pratiquement devant
Je veux juste savoir qui c'était
Je n'ai jamais été aussi proche de la scène
d'un crime et c'est un sentiment étrange
Je ne peux pas laisser tomber, ce n'était pas un
coïncidence, tuant devant la faculté
le formaldéhyde le mot le pendentif que j'avais
Puisque tout faisait partie d'un plan, tout le monde
sacrifie des victimes innocentes qui doivent
être immolé au profit de la divinité
la victime peut être
n'importe qui, je pense qu'il l'a tuée, qu'en pensez-vous ?
ça arrive avec, c'est quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
détails personnels, tout est dans le
détails
pour